don't starve do not just go get food
make food duplicates have died Virgil No
goddamnit Virgil Oh No
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to oxygen not included
there was a problem where people were
not making food there wasn't anything
wrong with the food like these were
powered everything was repaired like
they were working fine but for some
reason they just were not because we're
not making food and I don't know why I
have no idea why why were they making
food oh we're out of power god dammit
I'll get on the power oh my god I can't
believe that why weren't they making it
food I don't know I just don't know why
they weren't making food there was no
reason that they shouldn't have I mean
stress was finally going down but now
stress is up just because they're
they're out of food just eat eat eat eat
eat eat eat work out eat put coal in
this son of a [ __ ] I don't know why
it's so hard to do that alright
everyone's running which is good these
we're gonna build the battery back up
just manually yeah because I know the
microbe mushers probably take doodles
and oodles of power and that's no good
but you can only do so much you have to
get food you just gotta you know what
you can't why aren't people sleeping
over here coal to be delivered gotta get
the sweet
oh god no Sookie oh no MEAP god damn it
oh they starve to death
god damn it god damn it Oh God
oh my god stop there just max you vet
why were you you were trapped up there I
didn't know oh Jesus
just when I thought just when I thought
everything was going better just when I
thought things were actually looking up
suddenly things go down now everyone's
stressed because of the death of its
breaking things just when we were
pulling it back from the edge god damn
it max max was my favorite
I didn't mean to play favorites but max
was but we got to move on we got to move
on I know everyone's stressed now we got
to build these memorials so hopefully
the dead bodies just aren't going to be
sitting there she's I'm honestly hurt by
that I'm honestly hurt of all the people
to die
I can't believe max died
man those take a long time to make and
obviously not for poor reason oh yeah I
know I know I know
now suddenly we're down to helpers so
less work can get done so anyway for
this episode I really want to bring it
back to normal I want everything to be
working again and I think that was just
that was just the blow that we had to
deal with like I don't know how else to
make it better but I had a plan did I
had a plan to make things work now with
people gone you guys just aren't the
same guys it's aren't the same Oh Cecil
Woodrow Oh Woodrow you remind me of max
oh this duplicate is a little slow on
the update but gosh do they try Oh
Woodrow you're a good one cubed oh he's
a farty slow learner but he's robust in
a grease monkey I can't fault him for
that
Woodrow welcome on board god I'm like
literally bad I'm legitimately bad about
that I'm legitimately bad ah it's harsh
God and our entire like operation is
suffering for this loss like running out
of power run or none of everything I
mean I can't keep this coal generator
here because it just makes too much
carbon dioxide over here and it's not
even working anyway Oh Woodrow you're
trying real hard I appreciate that I
really do I appreciate that I'm gonna
make some I'm gonna make some outlets
for people I'm just gonna like this is
going to be a goddamn and it was going
to be the boot
room you're gonna build one there it's
gonna be just the art chamber and then
canvases hopefully this will help people
deal with some stress and bring this
room to decorum maximum I know I know I
know and I know I'm forgetting some ah
we're getting some algae though so
that's nice we got a lot of slime we got
we got three mega grams of slime in
storage which should be more than enough
because these just take 10 kilograms at
a time so we're going to have enough
algae for a good while so that'll be
good
to be repaired it's only so long it's
because guys actually make it that's the
problem here he's doing great Woodrow
I'm real proud of you Woodrow
woodrose really bringing it together I'm
gonna make these stress relievers are
going to be a priority I'm gonna make
these stress relievers a priority here
yeah I'd also like to do a priority mop
because there's this contaminated water
everywhere just from people vomiting
like that's literally all it is it's
just people vomiting there's only so
much you could do about that but you
know I just want to make sure that
people actually have something to go for
here if there goes another one just
vomiting where was that okay all right
so I know they're not happy with the
sweeping but at least they're doing it
all of his eating at the mess table I
haven't even seen someone there in ages
oh that's so nice
alright go to bed guys you deserved it
come on stinky aw come on stinky go to
bed save you can break it tomorrow I
won't even be mad if you break it
tomorrow let's go to bed buddy relax man
I feel like I'm talking to my family or
more than talking to you guys oh man I
don't mean to it's just like these guys
but like I remember them all I nori is
just a champ a constant chance like I'll
remember max and I like these
gravestones do they have Lenny
Virgil meet Max and sooky sooky was so
good too
Oh Sookie was so good I don't know I
just I remember him like I'm it's weird
I'm growing attached to these guys
that's why I didn't want to leave them
behind that's why I didn't wanted to
start over I wanted to like help them I
wanted to actually do this for them you
know I wanted them to be able to do this
and hopefully all those things up
they're going to be able to relieve the
stress but everyone's still stressed
anyway man we're running out of oxygen
we need more algae we got to get those
algae producers up oh they're out of
power that's the problem
okay ah all right we got to prioritize
some power here okay
they're busy breaking them that's nice
which she suckered out before she could
finish it
oh you broke one you started running in
the other aisle it's still nice no
stinky like I said I'm not actually mad
at you oh you hunkered out before you
could finish out there you go right back
to it that's a champ
that's a champ right there all right so
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna I'm going to
keep playing for a bit I'm gonna get
back to a point till we at least get
back to where we were before everyone
died would be awfully nice but I don't
know how long it's going to take but
we're gonna get there guys we're gonna
get there all right so that's a little
better I'm going to bring everything
back down to five just so everything is
everything's 5
so I want everything to be normal no one
to really deploy or does anything over
the others now yet anyway
batteries are all full actually every
single battery is full that's nice now
I'm going to braise these bio distillers
to six and hopefully that'll be
something dress is still hot I can do
something for them here because I want
to make an easier way of travel through
here just so there's a way to go through
on the inside that people don't have to
worry about it we've got another problem
coming soon water it's an obvious
problem these things are finally cooling
down to the point where they can
actually grow which is nice it'll get
there sooner it's just going to be a
little bit and they're relieving stress
by decorating which is nice and I just
don't know why these things aren't
getting filled new person all right what
do we got
whoa what happened there new person we
got Zeke pier and chuan Lee Twinkle Toes
night owl with Lerner narcoleptic beak
the bodybuilder huh kind of like ah I
like narcoleptics I think it's cute plus
you get extra sleep whenever you need it
whoa what is that AM orb more but oh God
a more bazan you vet's body what the
Clark
[Music]
agile disease-ridden invertebrates
attracted to decomposing carcasses and
deceased organisms ah ah that's morbid
that's why it's called more boy god
damages convert algae we have so much
slime just do it these are these are top
priority I don't know l-look I do not
understand what's going on here there's
slime they're not putting it in the
slime in the bio distillers they're just
not doing it why aren't they doing it
I'm just going to put this right by it
and I'm gonna have them destroy this I'm
gonna have them destroy like this and
it's just gonna pump contaminated oxygen
here but what else can I do like I don't
know what else it wants from me and can
someone please just put them in the put
it in the goddamn bio distill it why is
no one putting it in the goddamn bio
distiller this should be working it's
right there what more do you want
we need algae we have to have it
everything's just going to [ __ ] because
they will not put the [ __ ] slime in
the bio distiller please I'm begging you
guys just put it in that's all it takes
everything else is baseline priority
except for that way maybe maybe this
whole time I didn't have a tough point
then maybe it was full and not pumping
that what it was
I hope I hope that's what it was because
if that is maybe maybe but maybe that's
a big Navy if I got the puffed up here
doing this thing that was it that was it
that was it that was it oh my god that
was it oh oh oh oh that was it it didn't
have an outflow of course it didn't oh
no oh no oh no that's what it was they
didn't that vents oh my god this whole
time this whole time we could have had
all the algae we needed and I was too
much of an idiot but at least at the
very least we're gonna have what we need
oh man we better we better survive long
enough to this algae production go in to
effect hello new person it's still helm
a Joshua or Elinor naturally robust that
sounds good we could use a physician
that doesn't get sick it's awfully good
for us good it's good it's finally
flowing we're finally able to make
oxygen now it's finally working
and then hopefully these are going to
get up and running because we need to
feel we need these deal with the carbon
dioxide but oh my god if this actually
finally works again I'm going to be so
happy that I'm going to lose my goddamn
mind and I'm going to make another
storage well I'm just going to make one
of these this is raw material and also
and this [ __ ] is we not not let's not
make that one contaminated dirt that's
good okay so what I'm doing is I'm I'm
gonna make I'm going to solve all our
problems on one because number one this
puff up here is at the top and
contaminated oxygen likes to flow
upwards I'm going to eventually replace
this with vents no I'm not going to do
gas permeable tile fare building
meltdown build it wait what is this
building meltdown what and I've got them
there whatever fine fine but what I'm
going to do is this these are going to
dump their contaminated water down here
and then I'm going to put a pump here to
push water out this way I'm eventually
going to reroute these over here to I'm
going to build all this out but so that
contaminated water is over here because
slime is regurgitated into contaminated
water this thing constantly pumped out
slime it puts out a lot of slime so
that's a constant supply of slime
mmm that gets recycled over here turned
into water I'm gonna purify the water
into good water because we're almost out
of water which is very bad and then
everything is going to be okay right
that's how this works
maybe I shouldn't have killed that Puft
it's all wouldn't have happened if I had
not killed that pump there's the one
thing this is going to be with the
bridges I'm just putting tile there so I
can put pipe through it without liquids
flowing through because eventually I'm
going to reroute these so that's fine
because I can just reroute these two
shunt over there without too much issue
I suppose you can just build right
through that okay so you cannot do that
you can't lay pipe where wire is that is
a big no-no okay so pipe and wire can't
go together but that's fine that is fine
hunters and fine we're almost out of
slime jamming house when we only see out
of slime I thought that was supposed to
last this a long time not that anyone
told me that that was the case but just
because it was something I assumed I'm
not giving up yet
not given up yet not given up yet given
up yet Gus died in an explosion what
what explosion yeah
who's Gus died in an explosion what how
do they even happen how did something
explode I'll be back I'm still working
on it and getting there it's gonna
happen I was saving this last pocket of
algae for just such an occasion such as
this where everything has gone to [ __ ]
and I'm in the middle of fixing it so
what I'm doing here is I'm creating
multiple stages of walls because I need
to get rid of I need to uh I need to
keep the water in here while also create
what I need to be able to build
everything else so this this has to be
made soon just because it is very
essential but I'm blocking off
everything so that this will be its own
contained unit I'm going to get rid of
this and create a new wall here so this
is just contained and where it is I'm
going to move all this stuff but I've
got to do this first so that way I'll
have a giant pool of contaminated water
and then this will act as the bridge to
filter it it's not ideal I know because
I've also got a lot of water here I need
to mop this just to get rid of this I
need to mop this I need to mop
oh Jesus is the last of the water that
this has to be mop all this stuff has to
be mop
they're gonna get that so then when that
built which is almost soon you'll be
able to do that they're mopping that
that's like it they're doing that first
which I really appreciate
that is the last of the good water maybe
we've got some food
each okay the algae starts to going back
because we got this little bit of algae
I'm assuming that's what filtered into
everything oh geez god damn it [ __ ]
there okay
so the water purifier is there that's
going to be top priority we are
officially out of slime apparently so we
got very little slime left I don't think
this one Puft is going to be able to
make enough make enough slime so we got
to dig more soon but not right now I got
to worry about the water first and while
they're taking the contaminated water
eels all right we got a I've got to
nullify everything back down to base
priority just because I don't want them
to starve to death they gotta go do
everything oh boy another one bring them
into the fold uncultured a nice easy
yokel twinkle toe and uncultured that'll
do good for me come on in Virgil all
right Virgil we got work to do okay so
I've got a pump here it's not pumping
though why it's powered yes it is
powered its submerged in water which was
a requirement must be submerged in water
to continue why did that break why did
that break why did that break whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa why
did that break
what the hell just happened there I'm an
old conscience why is this not pumping
why did that break I'm gonna reinforce
that just in case cuz that is weird I
should not have happened filtration
medium ah okay so it needs a filtration
medium so I know we have sand we've got
a lot of sand we got too much sand
awaiting material delivery obviously so
it needs sand so who's gonna give it's
and ah I got them backwards oh that's
what it is that's be out that's the end
oh I had them backwards okay that's
that's what's wrong okay so now that I
know that when you get out of this
overlay ah so this was going in the
wrong entrance okay so I need to instead
put the plumbing this goes in dammit god
dammit uh this makes things difficult
how the [ __ ] do you do that then okay
and then this goes from there I'm
actually first me no no no no do not
yeah don't concede construct that okay
so now I'm gonna put these at high
priority because I need this please good
so then be out I'm gonna go over here
maybe it'll work maybe that'll work let
me just assume that that's going to work
where I go saying nothing's gonna work
okay so we definitely got stuff flowing
through now I see that so it's going to
do its thing
oh we're starting the process apparently
come on finish it finish it finish it
finish it you're so close
oh one more come on there we go okay a
man we just need two yes and then that's
it whoa hey whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
okay whoa whoa Jesus Christmas jiminy
Christmas that works way faster than I
thought I would what the fudge okay we
got a new person coming in hang on let's
slow things down just a hair okay Gus
hideki McNair yokel flatulence
uncultured
I like McNair McNair come on any air
McNair
holy [ __ ] all right okay so we got the
water pump working ah a lot apparently
that it's much different than I thought
it would be because god it's really
intermixed but that that's working fast
it's filtering 600 grams per second so
weird but it's working it is in fact
working which is good god everything's
broken again that is working in sanely
well better than I ever thought it was
going to work okay but with this with
this I now should have a steady stream
of water with which to make my base out
of I should it should should be that it
should be that so this is good so I'm an
and the episode here been recording this
one for about over an hour but it hasn't
felt like it's because I'm having the
time of my life playing this game I'm
almost there I'm so close to getting
where I need to be I'm so close thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye-bye
[Music]